merci françois meyer danse
bonsoir françois weyergans ça va très
bien très bientôt son c'est votre heure
là ouais tout à fait un tout assez nul
pour vous les émissions alors ça fait 3
rentrée littéraire que votre éditeur la
critique vos lecteurs attendez votre
nouveau livre et puis c'est arrivé trois
jours c'est ma mère est sorti chez
grasset voilà et comme un bonheur
n'arrive jamais seul et aux chairs
publie votre premier roman qui datent de
68 et qui n'étaient jamais sortis et qui
s'appelle [ __ ] mais voilà alors
évidemment votre arrivée comme ça
redonne un grand intérêt à la rentrée
littéraire car vous devenez un
concurrent sérieux de michel houellebecq
pour le goncourt françois weyergans
les cartes sont rebattues non c'est ce
que veulent ils oui mais moi je suis un
écrivain je quitte pratiquement pas mon
appartement ni même mon arrondissement
qui est le premier arrondissement qui
est de très bon arrondissement et l'âge
publié on l'on me dit on me traite comme
si j'étais un député encore panne
électorale en réseau vous êtes un
candidat
de quoi envoyer pas de programme on dit
est ce que vous seriez le missile contre
tel destroyer j'entends savent plus
tombe des nues ouais le music roya un
peu quand même
à quoi ou nude ou encore le goncourt
il ya des gens qu'ils donnent un
définition alors faire le le résumé du
bouquin 1 avant de viser le pitch
maintenant et en espagnol
comment dit le pitch en espagnol ce que
nous l'avons loisirs le pitch à chaud
mais les choux mais je vais tout mais si
vous y arrivez où il est fort ben non
justement
c'est un écrivain qui n'arrive pas à
écrire un livre qui s'appelle trois
jours chez ma mère voilà le relais
schumann et si jamais il y avait fait
sienne sillery crise en aurait pas fait
une livre en fait y'a pas de pitch qu'il
faut dire arrêter
elle échoue mais ces deux là c'est de la
pure littérature évidemment ça se résume
pas vous surfez sur votre vie
quotidienne vos souvenirs votre culture
tout ça avec beaucoup de grâce et
beaucoup de désinvolture françois
weyergans
on pense au livre de bernard frank ses
meilleurs moments parce que cet art de
la digression comme ça moi je pensais à
diderot widi droit aussi c'est vrai mais
le guide rouge alors on dit souvent que
vous ne publiez pas parce que vous avez
du mal à écrire en fait je crois que
vous avez du mal à arrêter de corriger
non ouais j'ai eu du mal à publier
surtout il ya une grande différence
entre écrire et publier
ouais donc j'écris tous les jours en
fait je le travaille je travaille
beaucoup on voit beaucoup de fax des
facs soigner j'ai calculé que depuis
j'ai pas publier deux livres j'ai envoyé
1200 fac comme il faut les publie c'est
une matière molle d'heure ma petite
fille une petite fille qu'à six ans qui
voyait mais fâche est allé sur une table
elle arrivait alors elle me dit c'est
toi qui as écris tout ça je dis oui
alors il me dit mais arrête ça suffit
arrêtes tu as a suffi joue avec moi plus
chaud en fait vous dites je publie pour
arrêter de corriger quoi pour arrêter
d'écrire web publie empêche d'écrire
vous n'êtes pas fainéant du tout en fait
non
et là c'est un perfectionniste un peu et
ouais surtout j'aime me suis attaché à
une matière un peu difficile qu'elle
aime les rapports entre 1
un fils et sa mère 1 j'avais fait le
père déjà le perse puis france 2
françois c'est plus facile le père
croyait la merde plus difficile parce
que quand on est encore un peu dans le
ventre de sa mère quoi qu'il arrive et
j'ai voulu à la fois montré un fils
cadet mal un peu mentalement on est
déprimé et puis une mère qui âgé qui va
mal physiquement et papa danse alors
entre le fils qui va mal dans sa tête la
mer qui va mal dans son corps j'ai fini
par faire un livre qui je trouve va bien
ouais donc j'ai beaucoup bossé la santé
afin de survivre en bonne santé
voila voila mon pitch alors mon rythme
au monde comment la joue mais il ya
beaucoup de travail pour arriver à cette
fluidité qu'on appelle la mélodie
weyergans est d'ailleurs cessé cdu c'est
du boulot ça vient pas tout seul quoi
vous corriger beaucoup vous recommencez
vous jetez enfin bon il ya que ça peu
humiliant parce que spontanément
l'esprit humain produit des fera des
blés pas sans intérêt moi je me trouve
la tête de 30 40 pages que je trouve la
bonne du tout il faut repérer dans
quarante pages 3 4 petites choses qui
sont intéressantes et puis on les enlève
et puis on commet là et c'est très
curieux adversaires beaucoup de mes
confrères se contente de publier leurs
quarante pages directement moi je
travaille un peu plus
voilà c'est pour ça que publie pas
souvent parce qu'ils travaillent plus
que les autres j'adore votre point de
vue là dessus et voilà ça plairait
beaucoup à ma mère ça oui
le ciel je regarde suffrages maternelle
alors vous raconter votre vie
quotidienne ça commence tu fais peur à
tout le monde c'est la femme du héros du
livre qui s'appelle pas weyergans
léveillard graves comme dans franz et
françois dayon inquiétée delphine quoi
oui j'ai fait peur à tout le monde mais
j'avais alors on m'avait dit ça avec tu
fais peur tous tes amis ont peur pour
toi oui oui parce que je sors pas de
lire et là on tombe dans l'ambiguïté de
mon invention dans le roman et puis de
ma propre vie et je met en scène trois
quatre narrateurs pour être bien sûr ça
qu'on va pas me confondre avec eux
gilles pige en accumulent plus on croit
que c'est moi alors évidemment le
narrateur son travail piétine les dettes
s'accumulent et les victimes du fils qui
n'est victime des huissiers il est pas
si vikings que ça devant moi sur tourbe
et j'en ai fait un instit qui arrive
quand même et ça c'est le saviez
peut-être de ce que certaines personnes
dont mes héros font partie ont eu peur
de ont peur de commander avoir à faire
une réalité douloureuse
on en a peur de souffrir n'a pas envie
de souffrir on s'invente une carapace
qui peut être l'humour qui est une très
bonne défense et en même temps le prix à
payer c'est que on est un peu moins
capables de sentiments primordiaux main
levée un peu cynique un peu
désillusionnés donc
ça on n'a pas la spontanéité moi il
m'arrive plus facilement de pleurer en
regardant light ils pallient les soutifs
mais pas dans la vie ouais alors ce
narrateur qui n'arrivent pas à faire ce
bouquin il a plein de projets il a un
livre sur socrate il a un roman d'amour
qui se passe sous le second empire
un texte sur ussel et des cas et puis
sous le pseudonyme de weyer bits
un livre qui s'appelle coucheries qu'on
a hâte de lire alors alors la ville
montrent assez
ce sera mon prochain tube femmes
coucheries par veille orbite et que
comme ils inventent des douceurs de
surnoms d'ailleurs grâce au graphène a
couronné il se dit je pourrais écrire
coucheries et je le signerai tant qu on
y est d'ailleurs bits ouais là dessus je
reçois un coup de téléphone de mon
éditeur qui limon figé c'est trop mignon
parce que le bigdil m'appelle vous
reconnaissez notre ami il m'appelle et
me dit il ya quand même quelque chose
d'un peu vulgos sic dans son livre
s'éveille orbite quand même ils me
proposent à la place d'ailleurs glas de
ce prix paragraphe de mon prochain roman
un ami bien sur papier votre mère
évidemment qui vous n'arrivez pas à
rendre visite qui est seule en provence
qui à bientôt 90 ans et qui vous dit au
lieu d'envoyer des fax sa dizaine
d'amoureuse tu devrait publier un livre
s'ils ont les gens vont croire que tu
aimes oeuvre voilà la réponse j'ai
touché ans à coups de phrases mais je
voulais rendre la mer très émouvant et
je voulais éviter le piège de beaucoup
de livres on met en scène une mère qui
sont des livres très vite mieux en huant
ou pleurnichard donc j'ai voulu
construire un personnage de deux femmes
veuves âgées pleine de vie qui est comme
je l'emmène à fait sortir au harry's bar
à 4 heures du matin
je fais ça c'est fait draguer batterie
mais oui c'était pas un imprimeur et
c'était pas un imprimeur le driver
maintenance des bouquins si c'est la
vérité ou pas mais aussi besoin qui va
arriver en galante
il ya une chose que je me demande quand
même c'est bon la nuit qu'est ce que
vous faites bon soit vous êtes au mathis
barrez vous avez raison mais quand vous
êtes dans la pièce où vous travaillez
qu'est ce que vous faites vous envoyer
des fax que vous vous lisez qu'est ce
que vous voulez passer des années
entières maintenant je me le demande je
me demande un peu avant je me le demande
vraiment mauvais dans ce que le fond
l'accueil à ses effectifs qui a eu
autour de trois jours chez ma mère et
salomé maintenant à éclipser d'un coup
mais quatre ans de généreuses que je
faisais je pensais quand même
franchement j'adore gland des jeux comme
tout le monde mais comment vous arrivez
à glander pendant quatre ans un proverbe
japonais qui dit le peintre observe la
fleur pour leurs 20 ans il a peint en 30
secondes voilà voilà les voilà voilà
voilà déjà deux noms à lille il ya eu
d'autres trucs
oui c'est ça c'est ça quatre ans que
j'ai fait pendant quatre ans
chacun d'eux beaucoup travaillé alors
les gars les factions comme quand je
vois je n'arrive pas à écrire le roman
je me corrige écrit un sage des textos
si vous écrivez des gorilles ça fait
plus court savez c'est plus vraiment les
textos elle valait publier les textes
ils ont été publiés lors match mais déjà
il y avait un premier choix et je
voulais voir corriger plus bas à l'effet
que ça faisait pour ça c'est pas mal
allemand courageux alors voilà donc ça
c'est le livre qui sort aujourd'hui chez
grasset qui s'appelle trois jours chez
ma mère il ya votre premier livre
salomez n'est pas publié à l'époque tout
le monde pense que votre premier livre
c'est le pitre en fait n'est pas du tout
c'était ce à lommel si on a droit le
pitre il veut le pitch du pitre peut
être